Hãy bình xanh dự kiến trên thái theo 2 dây đoạn, tư tháng 12 đến hết tháng 9,
tòn bộ hành khách đi một xam 8,5 tuyên xa biết nổi tình được biển phi không cần quét thẻ hoặc định dành.
Hành phố sẽ thích toán cho đất biệt bình tại theo dân thủ từng chuyến, các tử thật tòn dưới 2 bên.
Saum thời gian này các tử quan tiếp năng xế hoàn thiện hả tâm kỹ thuật, công nghệ và hệ thống bán diện từng trên toàn mạnh lưới.
Phóng động của xa biết được đam sát qua GPS, các mình là mặc các định tàn quán lý, giám bảo đam rất đường dịch vụ.
Tư tháng 4 đến hết nằm, hành khách tiếp tục được biển vẽ nhưng phải sát thực bằng thành gân hàng,
viên tự, tại khoảng viên này đi, ứng dụng biệt trực hộ phọc quân thức diện tự khác, tích hợp bởi hệ thống bẽ,
tiêu cầu định dành ám dụng bởi tất cả hành khách vông người không tùy học sinh sinh viên, người có không.
Dưới liệu khi dần nối xóa chế hệ thống sẽ là cân cứ ước đẹ thành phố thành toán cho đình vì bàn tài theo số lượt khách tiếp tế.
Thấy cho dân thu chuyện xe, giữa ra đọn đầu. Thôi bán dân dân thành phố chính xác nhằm giảm gì vị đi lại,
quyến thích người dân sự dụng xóa thông công cầu, bó phần hành trế uống tắc bầu nhiễm,
kện giá mẹ phủ thông trên các tuyến trở giá là từ năm tối mạnh khi đầu mối lực, học sinh và sinh viên trả mang khi đầu.